in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Alex
and Ayla are with us hey guys how are
you good
welcome welcome where do you guys live
off st. Louis Missouri very cool welcome
to Nashville and here to do a debt-free
scream yes sir I love it
how much have you paid off seventy one
thousand dollars all three years in
three years making what range of income
during that time 90 up to just just shy
of a 105 excellent what do you guys do
for a living I want to stay at home mom
and I'm an IT sales very good very good
and what kind of debt was the seven be
$1,000 car loan student loan credit card
debt what was the big one
student loan certain how much of the 71
was student loans actually the car was
the car was 30 and the student loans was
2000 a big car Toyota Highlander
oh nice car did it survive or did it get
sold for those of you looking into your
radio her head drop Mama's car got sold
yeah there we go so 30,000 bucks yeah
Wow cool that helped it was a nice car
and the good news is that doesn't mean
you never have a nice exactly means that
you actually have one that you have
rather than it having you right later
right when you get the money to pay for
it very cool very cool
and so student loans how much credit
card debt credit card was about five
thousand it wasn't much we had a stick
we had a loan to my parents for about
ten thousand you guys were normal we
were normal you had a little bit
everything just kind of be popping along
acting like you're being grown ups
absolutely and how long you been married
five years okay so two years into the
marriage something happened what
happened I had noticed that you know we
were just spending more money and it
just felt like it was out we weren't
keeping up with what we were spending
and actually we had a we had some gifts
that came in from our way
the reception and she went to return a
pan from that that was a duplicate two
years later
exactly well we had a reception later Oh
so we she went it to take it back and
when I got home from work that day she
was unloading the car that she had
bought the whole set and like wait a
minute we did not only did we not get
the money from the pan we just spent
another two three hundred dollars and at
that point I was going we had got to
figure this out okay
all right so that you had the pan fight
okay and after the pan fight what
happened so then we buckle down we I
started looking for answers I started
looking for you know where are we gonna
find this and our church was offering
FPU and at that point we said we can't
even afford it it's just not even an
option and so I started listening to the
show I'm a huge podcast fan and I listen
to podcasts all the time I travel quite
a bit for work now and I'm always
listening to podcast be there was sports
podcasts or your nod cast and so that
was that was a big thing and came home
and said we need to sell your car
exactly exactly so and then so far it
was not having fun yeah and so it was a
little hard at first to get her on board
because I was that huh I'm guessing yeah
who came and said yeah
one of the ways that I that I did is
dishes are a big issue in a lot of
households and I said I'll do the dishes
as long as I get to listen to the
podcasts that I want to listen to and so
they were forced to listen to Dave
Ramsey while we were listen to the
podcast while I was doing dishes oh I
see and then after about a couple months
I could hear her in the other room going
when I'd shut it off go what do you
think he said it to those guys how do
you think that finished and at that
point that she was she was starting to
pick up and get on board
Rachel Cruise is really what got me on
board okay well gets Rachel some crab
what did she do they got you on board
well that was more of she's not a sassy
no it was just I could relate to her
ah you know I was watching her her video
blogs and following her on Facebook and
it was basically the same thing you say
but I'm a woman so I I kind of took her
advice and she's not as rough as I Marty
a smart aleck Azad Adam very cool so
that you guys did it all off the podcast
it was the podcast we took actually you
know
oh you ended up taking the class effort
we ended up taking it yeah we just
finished the nine week yesterday so at
what point did Alice say I need to sell
my car hello what when did that happen
right after we had re our three year old
uh-huh and it was it was I was it was
raining and I was frustrated with my
kids and I was like I just need sliding
doors I don't even care I just want
sliding doors um so I got on Craigslist
and started looking for Oh
sliding doors for the car just make my
life easier if I just had a sliding
doors I can push the button my son can
get in I gave my daughter in sliding
shut be on my way a professional kid
hauler
so highlander's like up you got it cuz
it's a SUV yes so I I decided that
that's probably practical for our family
and so sold the highlander and how long
had you been listening to the podcast
during the dishwashing at that point it
was a couple years a little while okay
and at that point you know re was born
and re has cerebral palsy and so the
that there the price from that was going
up and so we were realizing and then we
also needed the doors for that in a van
yeah so along with the $71,000 we also
cash flowed fifteen thousand dollars in
medical sure um throughout that time
that we had 50/50 nights in hospital so
you want to throw a grenade into yeah
yeah under budget is fifteen dollars
anyway exam yeah well you guys are
impressive and you're authentic to you
were being real
because most people fight when they
start this stuff
and some of them fight halfway through
it but they're usually comes a tipping
point somewhere in the middle where
there's like okay this is right I got a
big grown-up and I got to do this stuff
and that's why I was asking about the
car thing that's a big decision
especially after he came in and now you
got not only difference on the carpet
Jeff admit his ideas like it was even
harder yeah you know yeah and that will
Dave Ramsey guy so yeah well I'll tell
Rachel that she has a fan that's very
nice thank you for that very very cool
you guys are incredible I'm so proud of
you you got to feel great about yourself
feels awesome it's not real adult stuff
you've done here I mean it's very very
serious very fun you paid off the family
what the family do when you paid them
off that they were really good
throughout the whole program they were
they never asked for anything they never
asked you know they knew it was coming
but they knew they were gonna get paid
but they they were good they were in the
debt snowball yeah you know they know it
was it was their why do I think it's
your parents it is my parents jump run
okay okay good good
all right Alex and Ayla st. Louis
Missouri Austin and Ari as well 71
thousand dollars paid off in 36 months
making a range of 90 to 105 not to
mention 50 days in the hospital and the
sale of a highlander count it down let's
hear free scream I actually just want to
throw one more thing in we also we were
going out to dinner to celebrate our
debt free skirt celebrate that we were
debt free and while we were driving to
dinner my mom called my grandma had
passed away earlier in the year earlier
in the month and she called to let us
know that part of our inheritance was
coming in so she didn't she wasn't able
to help us with the debt free we were
able to finish that off but she got us
halfway to our baby step 3 Wow
so it's all I said we we saw that as a
god thing is these ones are finally
doing something right and figured it out
a man you guys ready to scream
way to go you guys
that was fun good job Austin you got the
countdown better than most of the adults
well done some of them count up all
right good job man and that's awesome a
great family story
hey this stuff of handling money it's
real it makes you deal with all your
stuff it makes you deal with your set of
assumptions on how you run your life you
know what I'm saying yeah and it's not
about Dave Ramsey could be about Rachael
Cruz but it's not about Dave Ramsey so
man those couple that couples free this
is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show so you have to
break the cycle you have to flip this
thing on its head and make it behave
you've got to get so fired up and wired
up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind